Good Morning, John
So as you may have noticed, I like to do all the jobs
VidCon is coming up at the end of this month, Lizzie Bennet just passed 50 thousand subscribers
SciShow and Crash Course and Truth or Fail and Ecogeek and DFTBA records; it's a long list
And sometimes people ask me
"Hank, how do you do so much stuff? You must have some excellent productivity tips"
And yes, I do!
Unlike apparently everyone else I put my pants on two legs at a time
I've developed a faster way of tying my shoes
And also a faster and more efficient way to ambulate
I predict within the next five years everyone will be walking like this.
People also spend a HUGE amount of time eating, and I stopped doing that and instead
I just ingest 2000 calories of muscle milk in one sitting
This has also dramatically decreased the amount of time I spend pooping
though it has really increased the amount of time I spend peeing, which is why I've developed
this special desk chair
"Did you see that email from..."
What's up?
Okay...
Another tip, I my medical procedures in bulk
Also, I get my computer to do work for me
for example, I wrote a script that goes to Amazon for me so I don't have to do it, and orders more Muscle Milk
cause otherwise I'd spend a huge amount of time just ordering Muscle Milk
And I also wrote a script that emails my wife romantic messages on important holidays.
I mean, I was really busy so I didn't write the whole program.  It was based on a Russian spam writing algorithm
Here's any example of one from my last anniversary
But my biggest tip for all of you is instead of actually doing things
just imagine doing fun things
that way, you can get the maximum of stuff done, while in the end making sure that you never really ever do anything
Yes!  Kidding! I don't like Muscle Milk!
God, Michael drinks that stuff, it's so horrible.
But for serious, I do do a lot of stuff and I am pretty serious about, you know, making sure I use my time productively
I use a thing on my computer called Rescue Time, that like tracks where and what I do while I'm on my computer
and it's great! It's sort of hilarious cause it's always like
"you spend too much time on YouTube!" and I'm like yeah, but it's my job Rescue Time!
But that leads to another point about how I have the awesomest job ever. I work a lot because work is more like a hobby for me.
So that's where a lot of this like "all the jobs! do lots of different things" comes from for me.
Like I just like making things.  It's one of the things that makes me excited about life!
I also have to say, that you know, I can be more productive because I have help!  Vidcon has a whole team,
Carver and Monica and Jenny and Lindsey.  DFTBA records has Alan and Sam and Kristen.
And then with SciShow and Crash Course, we've got a whole team.  I'd love to introduce you to them sometime, everybody, they're great.
But I think that's one of the things that I learned from this project with you, John
is that I like to collaborate with people.  And no, none of them are as good of a collaborator as you are
you're still number one, but I like to do projects
I like to collaborate and I like to be on a team. It's like sports, except you're actually doing something!
And let me be the first to say what works for me in terms of productivity is not going to work for everybody
I don't like rigid, micromanaged schedules.  I like to let my, sort of, like internal stress level decide what I'm going to work on that day.
If I get really busy and I freak out, just, you know, flip over Emma Stone's eyeball
And the funny thing is flipping over Emma Stone's eyeball, for me, is work!
So, thanks to everybody.  John, I'll see you on Tuesday.